(upbeat music)
- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
If you look at most of human history,
the top artists, the top
musicians were also mathematicians
and also scientists and also engineers.
And this convergence between
creativity and mathematics
and science and engineering
is only accelerating.
In the careers of the future,
algebra and creativity
are gonna be that much more empowering,
but don't take my word for it.
You're about to meet
some of my close friends
who can better draw that link
between algebra and creativity
and the work of the future.
(upbeat music)
- The math underpins
everything in our universe,
so it impacts every corner of our society.
But over the past decade in particular,
the advances in computer technology
and introduction of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
has been massive
and we're only learning more and more
and building better and better systems,
and math underpins all of that
and it's fundamental to
all of those systems.
And in fact, computer science
is inherently linear algebra,
so it's really foundational
to those scientific advances.
- One relatively recent
example that really inspired me
was the first real photo that scientists
were able to capture of a black hole,
the mysterious remnants of giant stars
that lurk all over the universe.
And it's the way that
scientists used creativity
and math to solve the problem
that was so fascinating.
You see, these black holes are so distant
that there is no single telescope
that is large enough to be
able to actually see them.
And the scientists came
up with this clever idea,
creating a network of small telescopes
distributed all across the
globe that were synchronized
to capture and focus the
same object at the same time
creating a giant virtual telescope.
Now the aperture of this
giant virtual telescope
is nearly the same size as
a diameter of the Earth.
And with that in place, the
scientists and engineers
were able to capture all
the bits and pieces of data
and put it all together
into the first image
of a black hole that is
53 million light years,
which is 318 quintillion miles away.
Now that's an impressive
use of creativity and math.
(upbeat music)
- In the future, in
order to add innovation,
students are gonna need skills
such as creative problem solving,
so not looking at things
from the same perspective,
being able to ideate, so
come up with new ideas
and divergent thinking, right,
the ability to come up with ideas
that are drastically
different from each other.
Beyond creative problem
solving, students will also
need to show adaptability.
So the ability to pivot as the world
and constraints around us kind of pivot.
The STEM field is constantly evolving
and it's growing as we
gain more knowledge,
so students' ability to
be creative and adapt
as the field adapts will
be critical for success,
and for the ability to
innovate as we move forward.
- Communication skills are always
going to be essential for
furthering innovation.
And this is because if you want to make
a scientific advancement, you have to have
a lot of people on your side.
So you have to have funding bodies,
you have to have other scientists,
you have to have people
interested in what you're doing.
So this means you have to
have the communication tools
to communicate with all of
those different areas of people.
So different ways that you
can learn to communicate
with them are through
things like presentations,
through visual aids, through videos.
When you're preparing for
communication tools of the future,
it's quite difficult to
know what those will be.
So if we think back to 10 years ago,
we didn't have things like TikTok,
which is now a huge avenue
for communicating things to young people.
So that is something that
we've had to adapt to
and to learn and tailor our communication
during this new area of media.
So having versatility,
if students are able
to take the skills that
they have and apply them
to new areas of communication,
they'll be prepared
for the communication tools of the future.
(upbeat music)
- There are so many
ways that you can expand
your creative and math skills without even
really realizing that you're doing it.
Like for me, I'm a big board game fan,
and I realized that there's so many games
that involve math and learning
how to solve problems.
And sometimes just when you're cooking.
I love to bake, and so I
feel like I'm constantly
using fractions and learning
how to do proportions,
just because I'm doing things that I love.
So I feel like the best way to expand
your mathematical and creative skills
are just doing what you love to do,
because probably it has
some kind of math in it,
and some kind of creativity.
- Try to connect what you're
learning to your real life.
It's really easy to be in the classroom
and think that it's
siloed, and it's orthogonal
from the world around you.
The more we can connect
what we're learning
in the classroom to our real life,
whether it be sports or entertainment,
politics, news, whatever,
the connection that you make
between math and your real
life will really help you
appreciate the skills and the methods
and find ways to transfer them
outside of just the classroom alone.
(upbeat music)
- One of the newest ways of
thinking about problem solving
for me is something that my
math professor would tell me.
He would say, "Don't
be afraid to be stuck."
And I think that a lot of the
time when we are doing math
and we get stuck, sometimes it can be,
you can feel like, "Wow,
this is a reflection of me
and my mathematical abilities.
Wow, maybe I shouldn't be doing math."
But really a lot of the
time, it's just an indication
that you need to spend
more time doing the math
or figuring out what
the problem is exactly.
If you haven't gotten stuck yet,
then you probably will
get stuck at some point.
So being stuck is just a part of math
and it's kind of learning what to do
when you are stuck is a really big part
of being creative in math,
and being able to solve
problems in the future.
- One example that I often use is I often
try to solve problems both in
the traditional algebraic way
but I also try to visualize
problems in 2D and 3D space
to solve them more visually.
And so I think the more ways that you can
figure out how to solve a problem,
the more ways that you
can eventually sort of
save in your toolbox and use later on
to solve other problems.
- There's lots of different
tools and resources
like apps and puzzle games
that are gonna help you
think about problems in new ways
and help develop that critical thinking
that you need to be able
to apply your skills
to a lot of different areas.
And sometimes even starting at the answer
and working backwards through the problem
can help you see a different
way of getting to the answer.
- Students can combine new ways
of thinking about problem solving
by trying to look at it
from different angles.
Anytime you approach a problem,
If you're just looking at
it from your perspective,
you're not gonna get a holistic
view of the solution space.
So try to have perspectives
and look at the problem
from multiple angles to understand
all the ways in which it could be viewed.
The more holistically you view a problem,
the more paths you look
at, the more efficient
and effective you're
gonna be at solving it.
(upbeat music)
- One of these that is
most interesting to me
is the field of robotics
and the different ways
machine learning will impact our society.
So robotics combines lots
of math, lots of science,
lots of technology, but
also socioeconomic factors
such as human and robot trust.
So how humans feel about
robots, how they trust them,
and human/robot teams in the workplace,
so how humans and robots work
together to accomplish a task.
And creativity will be
hugely important here,
so creativity is not
only gonna be important
in designing the robots,
they're very intricate,
very complex systems,
and it'll require creativity to know
exactly how to design
them to do their jobs,
but also how to integrate
them into our everyday lives
which is a total different
facet of creativity.
And it's actually a new way of thinking
because it hasn't really been done yet.
So even though there are robots around us
and we've seen them, you've got the Roomba
who hoovers your living room,
really where we're heading is
for robots to be everywhere
and to be a really integral
part of our society.
So preparing for that
change and using creativity
to figure out the best way to do that
will be a really important step
in innovation in the future.
(upbeat music)